remembering a loved one lost one year
later he was just a special
special guy gerard nieva's brother
donald ray says he lived and breathed
bicycles and it was something the two
shared before his life was suddenly
stolen it was pretty much his life he
would you know wake up thinking about it
go to sleep thinking about it gerard was
one of five killed on december 10 2020
when a commercial truck driver who was
high on methamphetamine swerved and hit
a group of cyclists on the u.s 95 near
searchlight we still miss them
we think about them every day shawn
tyrone who works at las vegas cyclery
says this crash really rocked the entire
community it was a very huge blow to us
i mean we all knew and love and rode
with
with the entire group he wants to make
sure these names are never forgotten and
hopes this tragedy will always serve as
a reminder we need to advocate for safer
roads for driver awareness
and not
not let this just get swept under the
rug and forgotten he and donald ray are
asking others to keep an eye out i just
think people should be more aware of
cyclists and think of gerard who loved
to travel anywhere on two wheels the
pain will always be there
briana remembrance ride will take place
tomorrow at 7 a.m we have more info on
that on our website now as for the truck
driver he was sentenced to at least 16
years in prison earlier this year
and again we will have more on that on
our website reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now